[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we have with us names
[Applause]
thanks for being here man thanks for
having me yeah dude
what's happening
so this dude really great standing
comedian if you guys have probably seen
him ig uh
funny stuff yeah i've seen him too he's
just kind of popped up what's up yeah
yeah the first clip i saw some of you on
the explore page
uh you're talking about asian hate and
then you're also talking about how um
you went to asian hate rally but then it
was just like a supreme drop online
i was like dude i like this guy yeah
east asians are on top of their [ __ ]
supreme man
i've never seen you all waiting in line
yeah and then they're like oh [ __ ]
you drop
give us some free [ __ ] no it was fun i
mean that that special that clip was
actually like i think i started with
that
as like oh this is going to open the
special like this is what i want to open
with it
and then i was i remember talking my
a lot of comments on this [ __ ] like
aren't you asian like you guys don't
understand comedy at all
i'm just saying that so i can make this
joke but
uh my best friend one of my best friends
in high school saw that that was like i
remember that time those bit is about
like this asian guy my friend johann
probably shouldn't say his name but he's
gonna have johan yeah yeah his parents
want him to succeed
his name twice
he did he went to harvard he's [ __ ]
killing it right now but uh
uh he got
some uh white kid hockey player called
him [ __ ] and [ __ ] johan was like
[ __ ] that and he just slammed him into
the wall i was like oh my and it was
like y'all was a big guy so this hockey
player just slammed into the walls like
at that point i was like asians you
can't [ __ ] with these dudes man
and i was like that from that point on i
was like i mean i just remember that bit
thinking
this time i'm going to start the special
off because
i wanted to frame it around
uh what was going on in the
world at the moment i think asian hate
is kind of like died down that that
whole movement i don't know what's
happened to it but the hate's still
possible
yeah that hit is strong
but uh uh but people marching for it i
don't know right now just us dude we
still march
we still march every week really
yeah one sort of we'll explain later
okay
that's all i'm thinking
but yeah well thank you i'm glad that
bit resonated some people didn't like it
some people but that's just how comedy
goes i feel like that's just what's been
happening like online especially with
comedy like there's like such a weird
new group of folks that it's like where
did you come from that that all of a
sudden people stop understanding comedy
i think it's just uh the distribution of
comedy has made it such that or comedy
is made such that
who wants something that resonates with
them can go find it
like if you want to only hear like uh
positive things and and things that are
like woke so to speak you can go find
that and then the algorithm is designed
to give that to you was a whack flex
[Laughter]
flicks of wack flicks that sounds whack
as [ __ ] who wants to hear of happy [ __ ]
it's like hoorah sjw yeah are you a fan
the thing is those people have been
around like comedians have been around
the internet has been around right but
what we've seen well at least for me um
the change is like right around the
hillary trump
um
campaign
people started getting way more
like politicized and jokes weren't so
cool anymore and things were happening
like and then it got crazier and crazier
and like i think in the height of kobe
like people lost their sense of humor or
something happened because
people that used to laugh at the same
jokes they completely flipped and now
they're not cool with it or i don't know
what it what happened do you find it do
you find that like in the clubs where
like i think people are more sensitive
let me cut you off but i i don't i think
uh
i think these
stories of like
uh and this is something i it's like
sound like a uh what's it called a
broken record but i think the stories of
all that are kind of like
over inflated i think this whole cancer
culture thing and all that is like
well well well
uh uh is a lot smaller than people make
it seem to be like you think like oh you
can't say [ __ ] anymore you can't say no
that's not true at all like go come see
me at the club this weekend it's like
not that i'm saying like wild [ __ ] just
to say wild [ __ ] but it's
it's definitely not like oh
boo
none of that kind of [ __ ] happened
but it's ridiculous most of that stuff's
relegated to online yeah for sure clubs
yeah yeah no online we felt it where um
our our videos would get like taken down
some of the content we know like our
channel got suspended like things like
that oh this one just kidding news this
one yeah like
like before
um
a lot of this stuff wasn't
being regulated you know or like we
would make a funny post on instagram and
then the you know robots don't know
satire sarcasm they don't know any of
that stuff and then they they label it
as violence or whatever
because one time i said um my you know
this guy was like dude how did you get
your arms so big and i'm like i beat my
girlfriend
[Laughter]
my ig account got put on probation and
it was because of a photo here
my g went on probation so it just i
couldn't make money off of anything like
because of a photo here a photo here we
were taking one outside and you were
just like shirtless as usual and then
under it was the ig story it wasn't even
a post it was ig story i reposted an ig
story and you're just naked in the front
and then i just wrote sex sells
oh my and then i went up my account went
on probation for like eight months you
like you look like a child when you're
naked yeah yeah yeah
he's got that tiniest little nipple i
was like what the [ __ ] it was probably
it just went off probation like a month
ago you read that google [ __ ] where like
some kid i mean some guy sent a picture
of his baby's dick to the doctor and
google like flagged at his child porn no
way deleted his entire account
reported to the cops and all that yeah
yeah baby well yeah i mean his kid had a
infection on his in his dick or whatever
so the doctor was like just send me a
picture doctor you sent a picture and
the google flag did this kid plug oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] got wiped
out so it wasn't that bad gmail's
watching dude
[ __ ] dick pics wow online does feel
more sensitive because yesterday i just
saw this dude some asian dude and it
made me feel [ __ ] like disgrace but
he was trying to call out like tnfa like
oh you know tina fey only makes these
asian jokes look at uh mean girls look
at this part oh my man shut the [ __ ] up
youtube
like he's like digging up things because
to me like comedy or pieces of art is
made in context of that time right so if
that was called at that time don't dig
up something [ __ ] 15 20 years ago
like if we're more awoke now then we'll
make comedy too or art
that that that
matches the social sentiment of the day
but when you're gonna dig up old [ __ ] to
me that's like the most bitch-made [ __ ]
in the world
yeah if you're gonna dig up old stuff
you gotta appreciate it like you know
old enough for kisses yeah yeah like
clint eastwood did well some stuff
remains timeless like asian jokes will
always be funny if they're funny yeah
you know what i mean yeah but like you
can't [ __ ] a 12 year old like it was
1958 you could do that it's different
time
in 1943
yeah yeah yeah before the war ended it
was all good
it definitely seems like if you're
willing to bring yourself all the way to
the club you probably have a higher
chance of responding well to humor you
know exactly rather than like the
comments somewhere is just like all
access to anybody so you're just going
to attract all kinds of stuff what's uh
what's cons what's most concerning is
the way
people access comedy now like before it
was like uh you know like you could
watch four channels or whatever it was
or you there's like 20 comedians who
like doing huge things now it's like if
you can get to like a 17 year old early
or 16 year old early with like your
comedy and your comedy is not
necessarily like
of old guard like rock and dave and all
them then it's like if it's just like
sjw so to speak stuff thanks
you might be kind of
those people might be uh
impressionable and they're like this is
what comedy's supposed to be it's like
no comedy is just whatever makes you
laugh like
like you just haven't been in a position
to to laugh at certain things or
or been made to laugh at certain things
so now you think that that thing isn't
funny whereas whereas you've just been
in your own echo chamber that's
concerning me but beyond that it's like
all this cancer culture [ __ ] all that is
just gonna it's gonna pass like the
pendulum always swings the other way and
like we're seeing it now with like
people who are blowing up now it's like
people are saying the wild [ __ ] and just
for the sake of saying it and they can
and they're doing great yeah and
i don't know what's happening on this
other side where it's like
i don't know what any
to use the term again sjw comedians who
are like killing the game right now
like i don't know i don't know anyone
selling out you know clubs and [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] this is how you know donald
trump is a piece of [ __ ] and yeah like
that's all getting that even that feels
hacky now you know yeah what do you
think about the comedian andrew tate
hilarious
my favorite comedian but andrew t oh
yeah i mean i don't know any of this
stuff i just know that he's been
canceled or like they've kicked him off
of youtube and facebook instagram yeah
and i feel like that is from what i've
heard about him seems fairly right
because that's supposed to happen what
people don't talk about
is that
i have i'm working a bit about this but
it's like
it goes back to how impressionable
people's brains are yeah it's like mr
rogers had it right
you get to these kids early and teach
them like ethics and values and all this
stuff very early that carries forward
throughout their lives yeah andrew tate
is gonna be talking [ __ ] about this how
you treat women and throw against a wall
and this and that it's like
you're talking to a 15 year old kid this
kid like think about the [ __ ] you
learned when you're 15 how wrong it
might have been and the stuff that you
were wrong about and that's just stayed
in your brain like that that doesn't get
talked about enough about like how
easily manipulated a kid's brain could
be so andrew tate being kicked off of
that [ __ ] i'm perfectly fine with it
because
he's it's targeting kids like 15 12 13
14 years old
or whatever
boys whose brains are easily warped and
that kind of stuff yeah i thought uh in
fifth grade i thought a rich man had a
low rider with rims that was the epitome
of wealth you're partly right
did you grow up on mr rogers too no no
my parents indians [ __ ] but they said
you can't watch that [ __ ] they're an
indian equivalent no white man is
teaching you nothing
because when i took away from that show
as a kid i was like man this
[ __ ] takes off a jacket dude i
got another jacket that's my favorite
part oh my goodness guys how many
you jackets see his whole wardrobe every
time that's that's how they live he
wears shoes in the house he has clothes
for outside and the inside yeah that's
crazy why not cardigan
he has pajama cardigans and everything
there's no indian equivalent no it was
just uh
mr rogers was cool i'm just saying like
like a role model or something yeah if
you watch that documentary if you have
seen it but if you watch that doc like
the biggest takeaway for me was like he
was just saying like
kids are impressionable you have to get
to them early and if like andrew tate is
going to take the spot [ __ ] he's the
newest rogers yeah he's [ __ ] if he's
taking over then he's got to go because
that's not right imagine [ __ ]
hezbollah was not youtube videos
teaching children how to behave well i
think i think that's okay
i'm a big fan so uh
is okay for the kids so this is why this
is why israel shouldn't exist
it's either hammer alex jones you know
so yeah yeah you gotta pick your i like
hasbro those are our top three i like
him when he was playing with the pigeon
and his old arch nemesis got together
and they were petting a pigeon together
i'm talking about
you're talking about the little kid yeah
i'm talking about hezbollah
[Laughter]
nick's like no i [ __ ] with this
dude
is different from hezbollah
y'all talking about the pigeon and [ __ ]
this guy's like what the [ __ ]
you guys want to talk about the taliban
borah had a funny one where he
dude he went into that store
and then
borat he went into a store and he was
because there's hummus and there's hamas
and then he's like why do you have a
hammer why do you sell for the
terrorists
yeah basically hummus and hamas we're
gonna strike that from the record now
we're gonna leave it in yeah we're gonna
find zuma we're pro
he's like oh you're typing the little
kids
i was like he's actually 19. okay
did you grow up in new york i grew up in
jersey oh jersey 40 minutes outside of
man uh parsippany new jersey greatest
town in the world uh when i went when i
was why is it the greatest town in the
world i'm just saying it's just
fantastic
mad indian [ __ ] mad asian [ __ ] it's just
uh uh
if you wanna talk logistically it's 40
minutes from the city but it's got
fantastic schools do you still live
there no no my parents lived there still
but like let's say you were to settle
down would you move back over there
by's about to convince you to move to
vegas for no reason
no no no uh he pitches everybody me may
i if i were if i were of the mind to
move to the burbs part of me would
definitely be a consideration but only
because my parents were there my entire
like a lot of my extended family is
there oh like i grew up surround like i
grew up learning that the way to
live was to have family as close as
possible yeah yeah and i think uh uh
that is something i never want to lose
because like i see like people now who
have to you know raise a kid or two with
like grandparents far away or whatever
i'm just like i understand that and
that's a
interesting position to be in but it's
definitely i want to like drop my kids
off i don't have any kids but drop my
kids off my grandparents my parents
place like all right peace out me and my
wife we're gonna go hang out for like
three hours or whatever okay you know
just like and like have that influence
on them and i grew up
i say in a special but i grew up like
surrounded by my cousins so i never felt
this sense of uh
other that
i think indians and east asians like a
lot of people
feel i think like i'm not sure if you
guys have felt that way but i never felt
other from the sense i was weird to be
indian i always felt other than the
sense like i don't want to be like every
other indian
you know i mean like it's a difference
is there a huge indian community in your
neighborhood yeah and is it all your
family members or
that's the whole community yeah no
parsippany parsippany has probably got
outside of edison i would i would and i
don't quote me on this from uh actual
it's probably the second largest indian
population in new jersey for sure
outside edison it's huge um and it's a
lot of
newer money it's like it people now but
when i when i was there it was it was
still big but it's not what it's now
like now they got patel brothers they
got like 12 different restaurants it's
massive but when i was there i think
what attracted people to parsippany when
i
when my parents moved there
uh my grandparents moved there it was
like
they're like one indian store
and that was enough to be like go get
indian groceries
they have they had an east asian grocery
store in like room 46 so that was enough
to have like east asians move there
so it was just like that epicenter kind
of just grew and grew and grew and now
is that store still there
are the indian stores yeah for sure yeah
of course it's a good community yeah
yeah
it's a it's a
i think you change owners but it's like
a it's a almost not a strip mall but
like slightly smaller strip malls like
four joints like dunkin donuts owned by
new people
indian restaurant
an indian restaurant you need bankroll
an indian grocery store all in the same
like i saw your stamina about duncan
were you talking about chilling in the
parking lot hell yeah man
saying you're about to start your shift
i love that joke man what were you doing
before comedy right before
i graduated in uh
08
college with a finance degree and so
no it was bad
what's that you hated it no it's not
that haiti i just like i had like a
three four three five at nyu which is
like decent but it's not three seven
which is all my friends had and they
went to like goldman and buckley's and
all this kind of [ __ ] and so i was just
like underemployed
i
recruited or i interviewed at like two
investment banks and then didn't either
get didn't get either one of those jobs
because i you know i wasn't the best
interviewer in a recession right yeah
yeah um and then
i was so like after i graduated i was
like i don't have a job how the [ __ ] am
i gonna do i like was underemployed i
took like an internship at
uh no i took a temp gig at bloomberg and
then i took an internship at uh uh the
economic development corporation new
york city and none of those were like oh
i gotta do this for the rest of my life
kind of thing
um and that was bored got on stage in
august of 2009 like at an open mic in
jersey and just like shits and giggles
randomly yeah i mean like i took a
writing class at nyu yeah uh like have
to graduate you know they do like like
10 week classes whatever took one of
those and it was like really sappy i was
like this [ __ ] is corny as [ __ ] like i
don't want to [ __ ] hear my parents
you know what
[Laughter]
and uh
that didn't that didn't like compel me
to keep going and then i was just like i
always with my cousins i was always a
funny one and like funny like in a mean
way but uh everything like a roaster
yeah yeah roaster and like talking [ __ ]
and like
saying goofy [ __ ] you know but that was
enough
[Laughter]
and i just got on stage and it was like
you know
i was like oh this
i could do this this doesn't seem that
hard
that was really it was it was really
just like this doesn't i never had stage
fright
the whole like fear period yeah i never
had stage fright in the sense that
i don't like looking people looking at
me hmm well you know like the stage
fright like
i don't know if this material is going
to work or like man i hope they like
this yeah but it's never like oh my
everyone's looking at me
it was never that it was just like man
that joke didn't [ __ ] man like that was
concerning but never like uh
uh a
fear of like sweating and people looking
at me in a weird way and like oh what
are they thinking about me that no that
never bothered me so i just got on stage
and uh like i said i had 16 first
cousins they all came to my first show
it was an open mic where you had to
bring people oh
i was like well all right i'll stack
this [ __ ] deck and uh
that was it yeah yeah that was it it was
like it was a pack night and then uh
that was august 19 2009 so like like 13
years and four days ago baby but what
about like the monetization model
because it's like you you go on stage
it's free right some of them you got to
like it's like you drink minimum yeah
you got to pay like how about like
getting it to the point where you're
like [ __ ] i'm unemployed
but i also need to make money like how
did you make it into a way you can like
live off of well that didn't happen
until i didn't
make money doing comedy
i still barely make money doing comedy
but uh uh
i was
once i got the bug
to be on stage i was like all right i
got to be in new york like everyone's
like you gotta be in new york and i was
like close enough so for about a year
and a half i was just
taking a bus from my parents place
to new york city to do open mics and
[ __ ] like underemployed making no money
like or not making any money at all got
an internship at my friend's hedge fund
and so that kept me in the city during
the day so then at night i could go
do open mics and stuff it's like batman
yeah
yeah just like it
finance man and uh
and then through that internship like
with that experience on my resume i got
an assistant job at a hedge fund so i
was just like printing [ __ ] and like
making copies all kind of [ __ ] but
it was in the city it was in like 40
minutes outside of new york north
so i could move to the city and like
commute to work and then come back and
leave at like five o'clock uh from that
job and hit open mics and i did that for
like that type of [ __ ] for a very long
time uh until
2016 i was at a family office
uh
as like an associate um like looking at
investments and stuff for trial in
africa and all that kind of [ __ ] and
then that
company closed
and luckily like i was looking for work
like cause we got like a six month
notice [ __ ] was closing and within that
six months like chris rock saw me was
like hey man you're really funny three
months after that he's like you want to
write for the oscars i was like yes and
then three months after that i was in la
uh like literally literally like three
days after my
actual job ended i was in la riding
with chris rock for the officers whoa
and that was my first writing job
and then for like and then after that
happened i was like oh yeah i'm i made
it baby i'm right for chris rock oscar's
happened governor's balls like uh right
after the right off the oscars like uh
sunday night
monday night i thought fame and fortune
would come knocking
i'm at the comedy store open mike eating
dollar pizza hoping to get on like it
was like that and i was like all right
so that's the reality of comedy
uh and then for like six months i was
looking for work i got a job with hassan
you know on his congressional
correspondence dinner which was before
the last correspondence dinner and then
uh um
for like three four months i was like
[ __ ] what am i gonna do like i gotta go
back into copyright i got maybe i can
use this oscars job as a copywriting job
get me something still that pays bills
and all [ __ ]
that didn't happen uh and then i got an
email from this woman named tina who
used to come to my show
bar matches which is where chris rock
saw me tina you made me saying hey i'm
working for this girl named aquafina uh
i like what you do uh do you want to
help write on her show uh her go 90s
show i don't know if you know this
enough but uncle finna had a go 90 show
which was like a verizon network show it
was like a talk show yeah yeah and so i
think
season two or three i don't think maybe
four i don't know what season it was it
was like me and uh uh her other uh head
writer
like and that was like that job
paid like nothing but it was enough for
me to be like all right you know what
i'm gonna do comedy like [ __ ] all this
i'm gonna just things will work out and
if it doesn't that doesn't like i'll go
back to being assistant or some [ __ ] but
right now for the next few months and
that was like september the next few
months september 2016 for next few
months i'm gonna just do
comedy [ __ ] and see what happens um and
then you know like
comedy seller had a bunch of i was
passed at the cello that summer so like
i was getting a lot of work there and i
was like helping pay rent a little bit
and then like comedy sellers tv show
that was popping off and i was like good
at the seller so they were like oh you
want to do this do you want to do that i
was like yes let's just keep going and i
was paying the bills and that that just
kept me motivated enough to
keep going and then uh
yeah that's it really that so like the
payment of
comedy amid turning into a a business
like
what is not said often enough is that
comedy like stand up for sure and any
pursuit in comedy is like highly
entrepreneurial
was like you got to either make your own
way and you got to pray for a lot of
luck because i got i got very lucky i
was in the right place at the right time
a lot of times like had i never done
that show at broken comedy at bar
matches like that girl tina would have
never seen me rock but i've never seen
or they might have not seen me at those
times
and like it was just like you know
a lot of it was failing forward but it
was like a lot of it was just like
striking the opportunity was hot and uh
that was it and then
2017 september
you know i got a text from my boy jay he
was like
hey congrats you're writing for snl now
wow
michael chan yeah yeah that's my guy wow
and i was i was on i was writing a pilot
for a sketch show um and i had to leave
that pilot yeah obviously uh to write
for snl and that was september
2017 to may 2018
and then
[Music]
uh that ended and i didn't get renewed
which hurt but it was like all right
that's that happens
and then i was like all right now it's
got to stand up i guess and i thought as
being the first indian to ever write for
snl
uh that again like fame and fortune
would come knocking yeah yeah yeah but
that that didn't mean [ __ ] you know that
doesn't mean nothing
it was just like all right good for you
are you pretty cutthroat over there it's
not cutthroat i mean i mean i was on the
update team so it was a little different
you hear you hear war stories from
people who aren't there but it's like
any other job where it's a it's a
high-pressure job like i'm sure you guys
have worked like high-pressure jobs you
know it's just like you got to get your
[ __ ] done and everybody on youtube is
pretty crazy
get your videos up but no it's like it
was just uh uh
from that that's like july i think july
2018
uh
the day the day i got the call i wasn't
going back was the same day i had to run
my set for the seth meyers booker
uh to do their show so it was just like
i know time to process that did that
show literally the next day i had to go
do
a week of uh road work at winnipeg
comedy work comedy rumors comedy club in
winnipeg
and uh i feel like i'm doing last call
with on that late registration album
[Laughter]
you know it's crazy you say like you
know uh
whether it be like luck or being in the
right place at the right time but it
also sounds like you had extreme
dedication for a long period of time
from ups and downs man that's what i
respect like it's cool that you point
out how many times you have to like
rework all over again yeah and it's not
just like one graph line going up yes
that's the truth though you can't like
relax and just be like coasting people
only see the results they don't see what
goes on behind yeah yeah there was never
uh right
at one point
it was like all right it was like a
point of no return you know like after
that after that aquafina gig was like
all right well
no one's gonna hire you when the finance
world if you've been mia for like seven
months eight months you know what i mean
like yeah that gap is almost unexpected
you like and you can't go from being an
associate like looking at investments
and stuff to then being like oh i want
to be an assistant like that doesn't
happen yeah you know so and if you want
to continue on the associate path which
might have been i might have been able
to pursue
you gotta forget comedy because you know
finance is still a [ __ ]
14-hour hour day at that at that level
you know it's like how to combine it
dude comedy and finance
entrepreneurship
[Laughter]
finance bro yeah i think the real
question here is was it your jokes that
got will smith to smack
man you wrote that jaded joker you wrote
that
i would i would have been a lot meaner i
would have been a lot more than chris
was for sure being so close to chris
rock how did it feel i mean
it must have felt way different
because for me
like um
we do our form of comedy here right but
for me like comedy it's like the sacred
thing where it's like we everyone should
be able to [ __ ] around because we know
none of us really mean it we're just
explaining and exploring different
thoughts and ideas yeah so for someone
to like so to me like comedy is like the
floor is lava the floor is lava right
and then so for will smith to take
something personal who's supposed to be
a comedian too and go that's not lava
that's carpet right i'm like
[ __ ] you ruined the whole [ __ ]
so like for me that's where where my
or my anger came from for you like how
did you feel
being so close to chris rock and kind of
seeing him
kind of like i don't know do an
anti-comedy act it was you know i
remember where i was it's like
buildings
[Laughter]
i was in the green room at the addison
improv in dallas texas and i was right
about to go on and i was only washington
because i think i just had it on in the
background like in the green room and
then they're like oh chris rock is up
next is chris rock i was like okay now i
gotta watch because chris is gone
and uh i turn it on i'm like oh this is
gonna be good chris comes out i think
says two or three jokes and then says
the
the jade one you wrote him
[Laughter]
sick line bro and thank you at first you
know like because when we were when i
wrote on the oscars in 2016
we would definitely do sketchy like
there was definitely bits where like you
know people do some [ __ ] from the crowd
so first i thought like i didn't didn't
look like a real slap it looked like a
tv slap for a second like there's no way
that he just hit him for real
but then when they cut the audio feed i
was like oh this is real like because
they don't cut the audio unless that
[ __ ] is like happening in real time
and then and then you could see what
will smith was saying like keep my
wife's names out your [ __ ] mouth and
that was bleeped and that was with no
audio and i was like oh [ __ ] like that
just happened like that was some real
[ __ ] that just happened i immediately
felt like
i i lost all respect for
uh will after that because like will was
like growing up was like i'm sure it was
for a lot of you guys
the [ __ ] dude yeah it was watching it
was like watching my uncle slap my dad
like you know what i mean like
yeah yeah like what the [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] does that happen and like
like i know a lot of people on chris
were like not swinging back and all this
kind of [ __ ] it's like that's the most
professional person on the planet i
think that was the way that he did the
right thing of course and he keeps
yeah it was like the greatest moment in
television history or something like
that yeah yeah and it was just like
such a crazy thing to witness i think i
went on stage and i said almost exactly
i was like that what a bitch-ass dude
will smith is and it feels like now
if i see him do i gotta fight him you
know like feels like one of those
moments like do you fight this dude now
because and then he gave us that
soft-ass apology like two minutes ago
i am ashamed of myself yeah the box
water and [ __ ] books on it can't shut
up will you making money on apology bro
you play an apology yeah you saw that he
hit the box water on his [ __ ] table
brand dealers apology video yeah damn
that's genius that's entrepreneurial
though yeah yeah
you gotta make money every way you can
comedy and finances
you